two young sisters who survived alone in
the California wilderness for nearly two
days are telling their story today
rescuers found Caroline and Leia Carrico
near Richardson grave steppe great Grove
State Park because the name of that Park
Grove State Park I was on Sunday the
girls are now recovering at their home
they were found alive and very well
about a mile and a half from their house
Jamie yuccas is in Los Angeles with how
the massive rescue effort went down
Jamie good morning to you good morning
the girl's parents say it's normal for
them to play unsupervised on their 80
acre property but this time around the
sisters found themselves in unfamiliar
territory and unsure how to get home
they just wanted a little more Ben Papa
I said to go a little far
five-year-old Caroline Kirikou and her
eight-year-old sister Leia went a little
bit too far during a hike in the woods
behind their home on Friday when they
didn't return their frantic parents
reported them missing awful terrified
and guilty spent two days crying my eyes
out looking everywhere we could think of
the look while their parents feared the
worst older sister Leia was going into
survival mode and it's starting to
drizzle so I knew we had to find shelter
fast and we had my sister's ring Jack
get to keep us warm we turned it
sideways so each of us had arm hole I
always stick her arms into it realizing
they couldn't make it home Leia tried to
keep her little sister calm my sister
cried the whole night so I told her to
think happy thoughts of our family and I
kept watch for us tonight I saw going to
the car was blooming baggy by Saturday a
search effort was underway with more
than 250 people from across the state we
heard helicopters and will yell at them
they couldn't hear us because though
murders early Sunday firefighters
Delbert Chumley and Abram Hill spotted a
trail of boot prints
we both popped out of the brush and a
slid under and there are these purple
rain boots and I was oh my gosh
the girls were dehydrated but otherwise
okay
they saved each other I'm the proudest
mom I raise superheroes the parents say
the girls have two years of wilderness
survival training through their
involvement in 4h that's a national
youth organization that provides
educational programs for kids Leia even
said she knows how to make a fire but
she didn't have to use those skills this
time around
fionna me I mean it's just something as
a mother when you hear her mother cry
yeah right it's irritable her head heart
health and hands and now heroes no so
forever stranded we now put one arm and
one arm and we can cuddle together I
love that love that let than her sister
and all our H what a happy ending there